what about the actual pipeline of
software engineering how easy it is to
keep updating Atlas like Duke continuous
development on it so how many computers
are on there is there a nice pipeline
it's an important part of um building a
team around it which means you know you
need to also have software tools
simulation tools you know so
um we have always made strong use of
physics-based simulation tools to do
some of this calculation basically test
it in simulation before you put it on
the robot but you also want the same
code that you're running in simulation
to be the same code you're running on
the hardware and so even getting to the
point where it was the same code going
from one to the other
we probably didn't really get that
working until you know a few years
several years ago
but that was a you know that was a bit
of a milestone and so you want to work
certainly work these pipelines so that
you can make it as easy as possible and
have a bunch of people working in
parallel especially when you know we
only have you know four of the atlas
robots the modern Atlas robots at the
company
and you know we probably have you know
40 developers there all trying to gain
access to it and so you need to share
resources and use some of these uh some
of the software pipeline well that's a
really exciting step to be able to run
the exact same code and simulation as on
the actual robot uh how hard is it to do
uh realistic simulation physics-based
simulation of of of Atlas such that I
mean the the dream is like if it works
in simulation works perfectly in reality
how hard is it to sort of keep working
on closing that Gap the root of some of
our physics-based simulation tools
really started at MIT and um we built
some some some good physics-based
modeling tools there
the early days of the company we were
trying to develop those tools as a
commercial product so we continued to
develop them it wasn't a particularly
successful commercial product but we
ended up with some nice physics-based
simulation tools so that when we started
doing legged robotics again we had a
really nice tool to work with
and the things we paid attention to were
were things that weren't necessarily
handled very well in the commercial
tools you could buy off the shelf like
like interaction with the world like
foot ground contact so trying to model
those contact
um events well
in a way that captured the important
parts of the interaction
was a really important element to get
right and to also do in a way that was
computationally feasible
um and could run fast because if you if
your simulation runs too slow you know
then your developers are sitting around
waiting for stuff to run and compile so
it it's always about efficient uh a fast
operation as well so that's been a big
part of it you know I think developing
those tools in parallel to the
development of the the platform and
trying to scale them has has really been
essential I'd say to us being able to
assemble a team of people that could do
this yeah how to simulate contact
periods so foot ground contact but sort
of for manipulation
because don't you want to model all
kinds of surfaces yeah so it will be
even more complex with manipulation
because there's a lot more going on you
know and you need to capture I don't
know things slipping and moving you know
in in your in your hand
um it's a level of complexity that I
think goes above foot ground contact
when you really start doing dexterous
manipulation so there's challenges ahead
still so how far are we away from me
being able to walk with Atlas in the
sand along the beach and
us both drinking a beer
we can out of a kid maybe Atlas could
spill his beer because he's got nowhere
to put it
Atlas could walk on the sand uh so can
it yeah uh yeah I mean you know have we
really had him out on the beach you know
we take them outside often you know
rocks Hills that sort of thing even or
surround our lab in Waltham we probably
haven't been on the sand but I'm a salt
surface I don't doubt that we could deal
with it yeah we we might have to spend a
little bit of time to sort of make that
work